[Music]
this is Chris Kahn from every damn day
and I'm here in LA with fans again and
sometimes they in and we're going to ask
people if it's a fan or fraud cheeto
dust makeup is this a fad or fraud she
don't make up that's a fad yeah this is
absolutely a fad this is a real picture
from the real website that's actually my
shade I think these are licorice straws
yeah
whoo dissension amongst friends 11 I'm
not sure that what they're doing I don't
want to assume anything
all right this is actually a fraud
really yeah okay next Dan bags oh my god
it's like a fanny pack muffin like with
using the fake dead bellies let's say a
fad yeah
I'd say it's a fad I think this one's a
fad this is absolutely a bad this would
you wear that back sure I'm ruined it
you already know I mean just wait till
you get the real dad bags tell me I mean
they come next flavor phone cases fraud
this is unsanitary
would you trying to start a business
yes okay these are called extendo jeans
they're about nine feet long why would
anyone wear them I think fat I'm gonna
say fraud baby this is a bad people you
could buy them online they cost 500
bucks no fruit garbage milk aka compost
milk okay that's a fraud fraud fraud bad
fat you wouldn't drink through garbage I
wouldn't I don't think okay it's
definitely a fraud but I think it's a
good business endeavor
hi feelin okay just called the vampire
facial it's when you take blood and you
smear on your face you let it sit for a
little bit do you wash it off real trend
fast yeah I know that's a fact
absolutely real and this is a real
picture and it's creepy I don't know
where the blood come from that's the
scary part here real Aegon's is just a
fad or fraud nah okay these ladies I
hope that's a fried saying those are
kind of higher actually that's my fan
bingbing last but not least truck nuts
for shoes okay now you got a truck
that's on trucks there you can put it
right on your shoe to let people know
you're not around when you walk
unfortunately this is a fraud I think
they're pretty cool and I want to
[Music]
that is aqua fair